- At a virtual court hearing
for alleged US Capitol rioter,
Anthony Antonio,
his lawyer argued that he
committed those acts because
of Foxitis or Fox mania.
Because the guy lost his job
and believed everything that
he was watching on Fox News.
and that's why he committed
the crime of rioting.
In answer to your questions,
no Fox News is not going
to face any repercussions
as a result of this even if
these allegations are true.
Because remember,
people are responsible
for their own actions.
Love or hate Fox News,
they don't make people do anything.
I would love to tell you
more about this court hearing
but it was interrupted
by fellow alleged US Capitol rioter
Landon Copeland who heard these words,
was incensed and just
went on a complete rage,
interrupted everything.
So in the future,
we're gonna be seeing a
lot of these guys in court.